[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy that
always finds the devil in the details
and this video we're breaking down the
second part of lucifer season five
the new entry has a lot to unpack from
it and throughout this video we're going
to be recapping the ending
giving our review of the show and
discussing what could be happening next
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out then i
highly recommend that you check out now
please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy the
video and make sure you subscribe
for breakdowns like this each and every
day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our lucifer
ending explained okay so this video is
going to be recapping a lot of the
season
but if you want to just skip ahead to
the ending discussion then time codes
will be linked below
i feel like we have to talk about the
overall themes before getting into that
but
i'm giving you the free will to decide
how you wanna watch the video
now lucifer has had a bit of a bumpy
ride in terms of release dates
the first part of season 5 dropped
almost a year ago
and since then we've been eagerly
awaiting the follow-up
in june 2020 it was announced that the
series was being given a sixth season
and both in part two were filmed
together so everything is in the can
and there's even speculation that the
final 10 episodes could be dropping
within the next six months
however netflix may want to put some
time between the two entries
just so that fans have something to look
forward to now as for the first part of
season five
it was very much better the devil you
know with the battle between michael and
lucifer coming to boiling point
the closer that lucifer got to chloe the
more vulnerable he became
but when the pair realized he was still
invincible
questions over his love for her
continued chloe very much suspected that
subconsciously he no longer had feelings
for her
and this is how he was able to withstand
being shot by dan
michael very much manipulated things
behind the scenes
and pushed mace into turning against the
character in her quest to find his soul
we discovered that this was all tied to
lucifer's ring which contained a stone
from the garden of eden
maize believed that she'd finally be
able to get a soul if she was able to
get her hands on it
and she joined michael's side in trying
to defeat him time was frozen by a mana
deal
just as lucifer was about to admit his
love for chloe and we discovered that
michael had manipulated him into feeling
like his son wasn't a celestial
amena deal obviously didn't want to
watch him grow old and die as a mortal
and this moment pushed him over the edge
a big battle in slo-mo ensued
and i just want to give myself a pat on
the back for going this long
without mentioning mephisto anyway
everything culminated with god turning
up
and after bragging at the fight the
opening episode of part two
focuses on family it's always family
now after being introduced to his
grandson god pulls
everyone together for a last supper in
which they all
attempt to sort their differences out
over the dinner table i love how when
lucifer arrives he sits at the bottom of
the table
and with the others at the top it forms
the shape of a cross
michael and lucifer have it out and it
does become slightly easier to see
things from the former's point of view
i did actually have difficulty
understanding why he hated lucifer so
much
but after hearing how he felt cursed
about the face of someone whose shadow
he would forever live in
it did hint towards his mentality he's
filled with hate
and it becomes clear that this emotion
in some ways is due to his dad
michael is banished from earth but this
further scorns him into going down a
darker path that somewhat mirrors
lucifer's
the fact that they are identical and
reflect each other works really well
and he ends up starting his own
rebellion much like how his brother did
in the bible
i guess the apple of eden doesn't fall
far from the tree
and it leads to him going on a great
noah's ark throughout the season
now god very much has to confront that
he's not been there for his kids
and due to the family being unsure if he
even loves them
it shows that he's failed as a father
which i mean
respectfully now he's very much an
opposite to amena deal
who showcases what it's like to be a dad
who would do anything for their kid
god is very much presented with the idea
that he's incapable of love
detached by emotion and therefore unable
to get hurt
we see something similar developing
linda who of course was looking
over her estranged daughter adriana she
too gets in trouble after doing anything
to protect the one that she loves
and it shows that caring for someone
ensures that trouble will always follow
thus the idea of watching the people you
love from afar
similar how linda and god do allows them
to remain in control of the situation
and it stops their emotions getting the
best of them lucifer early on
very much adapts this mentality and
tells chloe he can never love her at the
end of episode 1
which leads to him being alone and on a
path of succession to take the place of
his father
now even though lucifer used to be the
embodiment of evil he has a lovely
singing voice
and the musical episode is one of the
standouts in the show
thomas and the rest of the cast really
give their all
and watching every breath they take and
every move they make
means i'll stay forever watching you not
you
now i really enjoyed this creative way
of telling this story
and hopefully we get something like this
in the next season as i'd love to see
them
susan boyle in hell's fire i don't even
think that pun works
but we finally get the answer to what if
god was one of us
as the father makes himself human he
starts to accept that perhaps he raised
lucifer wrongly
and he messed up the balance between
controlling him and allowing for free
will
he also tells mazakin that it is
possible for her to grow a soul
and i loved watching dennis haysbert
having fun with the role
he has some really good interactions
with dan and i think the arc that god
goes on
very much centers around him actually
being present so he can see for one how
his actions have
influenced his children and the rest of
the world it's quite a fascinating
character study
that not only delves deep into what it
means to be a father
but also what humanity expects from god
and how they perceive him
it's a really good analysis and speaking
of character development
we also get a dan centric episode where
he learns not to be judgmental towards
lucy
see everyone all you have to do to make
people think it's mexico
is put an orange filter over it now they
give a nod to seven when he escorts
someone across the desert
who keeps asking what's in the box this
entry very much feels like lucifer's
version of david finch's the game
and he reveals that it was all part of
his plan to show down the truth
it's another fascinating entry that
highlights the themes of the series
which is trying to see things from the
side of other people
we also get the return of eve who you
will remember was a big part of
lucifer's life
early on in the show's history after
realizing she was happiest with maize
she engineers and encounter in order to
get close to her
maize realizes that she's her soulmate
and finally accomplishes her goal
lucifer also grows and decides that he
will put his foot forward
to step into the shoes of god after
ruling hell
and learning about humanity firsthand he
seems the most adept out of the family
and it allows god to finally retire he
leaves with his wife goddess
who is once more played by tricia helfer
now you may remember that goddess
created floods and plagues to wipe out
humanity
because she was angered over her husband
putting them above their relationship in
children
goddess was cast into hell and banished
from heaven
but god now realizes that he should have
put a focus on them above
everything else he tells lucifer that he
loves him
and is proud of the man he's become
which is something that he would never
have done before
instead of casting the role of being a
father and husband to the side
he finally embraces it which is of
course muradin lucifer who admits to
chloe that he does love her
guarding goddess depart to her dimension
and chloe signs up for the role of being
a consultant
should lucifer end up gaining the
position however as god did not name his
successor
it means that it's open for applicants
and michael starts to enact his
plan to gain the job he begins to
assemble a flaming sword
and dan gets caught in the crossfire
which leads to his death
it's a big moment in the series that's
made even more gut-wrenching when it's
revealed that
due to his guilt he went to hell instead
of heaven though we never get a
revelation on this
i do think that season six will very
much center around putting him in his
rightful place
another character is dead that doesn't
mean he's gone for good
lucifer as a show is very much about
growth acceptance and change
and the ark he's been on though cut
short likely isn't over yet
what's on netflix did post that kevin
alejandro who plays him
is returning for the next season and
whilst we can't verify this yet
it does seem likely that he'll be back
originally lucifer wanted to prove he
was worthy of being god
so that he could prove he was worthy of
chloe however the death of dan makes him
realize that he has to become god
and this puts him into an all-out war
with his brother michael says he will
allow lucifer and chloe to spend
eternity together if he vacates running
for the role and at the los
angeles memorial coliseum they hold a
vote between
all the angels to decide who should
become god with a bit of social
distancing
it's revealed that michael is
controlling through fear because he
bears the flaming sword
after the angel to realize that lucifer
wished to become god because of love
two of them end up switching sides which
stops the vote from being unanimous
maize arrives with an army and michael
and lucifer take on each other
man to man god to god now lucifer is
able to strip the flaming sword from him
with the help of chloe but asriel
arrives to show that death is imminent
and chloe is killed by michael in her
final breaths she says she doesn't blame
herself for dan
which means that her soul gets to go to
heaven even though he's banished from
there
lucifer travels to the afterlife to find
her having a picnic with her father
he bumps into the character whose soul
was damned to hell in the first part of
season 5
and learns that he's managed to make it
to heaven after facing his guilt
it's a touching moment in which he
returns the favor and lucifer gives his
ring to chloe which allows her to go
back to
earth using the holy artifacts she's
able to kick the crap out of michael
and lucifer returns to earth and forces
him to bend the knee
although it's never explained exactly
how he came back the fact that he
accepted he loved chloe and also in some
ways accepted the role of god
i think removes his banishment from
heaven and means that he can do what he
wants
using the flaming sword lucifer cuts off
his brother's wings
but he gives michael a second chance the
angels bow before him and the season
ends with him saying
oh my me instead of oh my god this
ending of the season
of course reflects the opening of part
two as god stood atop some stairs with
the angels before him
much in the same way that lucifer does
here however i don't think that it will
be all plain sailing
and god himself in the season show that
it's impossible to take on this role
and to love someone the main reason that
he and goddess ended up being pitted
against one another
was because he put the job over her it
was only in retirement that they were
able to have a relationship
and i think that chloe will very much
experience the same issues
being god is of course a powerful
position and i actually feel that it may
end up getting too much for lucifer
and that amenity will take on the role
come the end of season six
i actually have a theory that lucifer
might make himself mortal so that he can
have a proper life with chloe
free of all the trappings and that that
will be the conclusion of his arc
let me know below if you disagree but we
actually already know the titles for all
the episodes in season 6.
episode 9 will be called goodbye lucifer
with the finale being titled partners to
the end
thus we can surmise from this that the
lucifer mantle may be dropped
and that he will be spending time with
chloe going forward
as great as it would be for him to
become god i just can't see it lasting
and now that he's taken michael out of
the running for it i think
all that remains is for someone else to
take over the position
therefore i think that a mana deal will
become god lucifer and chloe will go off
and have their own lives
and in hell mazakin and evil reign
now as for my thoughts on this part of
the season i kind of have mixed feelings
about it
to me it looked like a lot of the finale
was impacted by kovid
and at points it felt slightly rushed
there's also things that
i've just stopped caring about i'm being
honest certain things i just don't care
about anymore
unfortunately i feel that the main story
is so strong
and clearly where our interests should
lie that anything not focused on it
feels like a bit of a drag
there's a couple of murder plots in the
season especially early on
that i just didn't really connect with
and i felt like they were a necessary
filler
even with appearances by john glover i
think that it just kind of got in the
way
and i would have preferred to have the
focus on god and his replacement
they linger quite a lot on the
unnecessary and in the opening of the
season
god basically shows up breaks up the
fight and then it's 30 minutes before we
get back into it
even things like the excellent musical
episode are pushed to the side for some
investigating
i feel like most of it could have
probably been cut and i'll be getting
some flames in the comments for saying
that
but at this point i'm far more
interested in the overarching story than
the whodunit of the week
there are certain bits like in episode 3
in which they integrate the plot into
the investigations
but when they're standalone i'm not sure
how well they work
that being said it's a nitpick and it's
not like the show doesn't work because
of them
the season still gels together really
well and this is probably the most
in-depth look that we've had at the
characters and the reasons why they've
ended up becoming the way that they are
i think lucifer's overall arc of going
from the ruler of hell to heaven has
been a good one though
and tom ellis as always does a great job
of leading the cast in show
the fact he played michael as well is a
testament to his talent
and i swear that's not a pun overall i'm
very excited to see what happens next
the character is once more again at a
point where
anything could go down lucifer season 5
part 2 has some great moments in it
and it gets a 7.5 out of 10.
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on it so make sure you comment
below
and let me know as a thank you for
interacting with the video you'll be
entered into a prize straw on the 30th
of may
in which we're giving away three copies
of the godzilla versus kong collection
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the season
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else that's devil
related and make sure you check out our
breakdown of the conjuring the devil
made me do it which will be linked on
screen right now
we've gone over the entire movie and
talked about the real life story that
inspired it
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sticking through the video
i've been paul and i'll see you next
time take care
peace